okay
hello and welcome to this webinar
this webinar is dedicated to our
upcoming program
called omix logic bioinformatics for
precision oncology
so you might be asking yourself what is
onyx logic and
to tell you about it i'm going to just
share a few brief
points that are a central component of
our vision
so the goal of onyx logic programs
is to provide training in bioinformatics
enabling independent research
guided by mentors and peer example
it is also to develop a community with
shared passion for data-driven research
and an appreciation of citizen science
we also seek to enable students
clinicians and faculty
of all backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research
using latest technology in life and data
sciences
and so over the course of the past
several years our team has been
collaborating with a number of academic
institutions around the world
that have participated in content
evaluation
curriculum review and project design and
so
as a result of this we believe that the
omics logic curriculum and programs
have been thoroughly evaluated and now
we have
evidence that they lead to excellent
outcomes
so as you have joined this program and
this webinar
we ask that you also join us on social
media so we have these two
groups one on linkedin and one on
facebook
i think what's interesting about this is
that we have been able to attract
a very high caliber of people both from
research
industry and different academic
institution environments
and so we are looking forward to
interacting with you sharing
recent updates from different research
articles related to different topics in
bioinformatics
and also learning more about your
interests
so what we have what we will discuss
today and what we prepared for you
and throughout this program is the
result of hard work by an amazing team
led by company co-founders dr alfred
tauber and dr lean and brodsky
dr alfred tauber comes from a medical
background and has extensive expertise
in oncology immunology biochemistry of
inflammation
and has been recognized internationally
for his generous support of many
research projects
and initiatives that support data
science training and applications in
medicine
and dr leonard brodsky is currently the
director of the tower bioinformatics
research center at university of haifa
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
he has a background in mathematics and
has numerous publications in mathematics
and bioinformatics
and over the course of his career has
developed multiple novel algorithmic
approaches
to biomedical data analysis the rest of
the team
includes experts in bioinformatics
computer science
and training so some of the people that
you see here will also be presenting
today
now this program was designed to address
some of the challenges that are common
to research
in oncology where omics data is becoming
central
to the research that drives novel
diagnostic approaches
as well as therapeutic insights into how
cancer can be treated better
so first of all i wanted to share with
you a little bit about
why cancer so cancer is one of the
leading causes
of morbidity and mortality worldwide
in fact it is the second cause of cancer
after
cardiovascular diseases but as you can
see on this map
it is a problem of the western world
and there are several reasons for that
but we might already consider how it's
related to
lifestyle the length of
life so aging and also consider
the different types of approaches to
treating
treatment and prevention of cancer as
well
and so because cancer is primarily
primarily a disease that is manifested
at the cellular level we understand this
as a progression from healthy cells
to abnormal cells to then cancer that is
contained
or pre-invasive and then eventually when
the cancer becomes to spread throughout
different tissues
that is typically when it is detected
and then treated
and so part of what we are going to be
speaking today
is the research that is enabling us to
screen
for and identify cancer early on
also developing techniques and novel
insights into the molecular mechanisms
of cancer
that would allow for better treatment of
cancer overall
so one of the things that characterizes
cancer research
both basic and translational oncology
research
is the collection of high throughput
molecular data
that could describe different types of
mechanisms that regulate
gene expression and the regulation of
subcellular processes
that might lead to cancer development
and progression
and to study these mechanisms not
everything is possible to do
with patient data so a lot of it has to
do with
animal models as well as cell line
culture and organoids
that allow us to study many different
perturbations
at the subcellular level and so as a
result we are seeing
this increase in big data
data that comes from next generation
sequencing
and other types of omics data that
together
can help us find answers to this
important condition
now one of the things that we will want
to do in this program
is provide you with an opportunity to
gain insight into how to analyze such
data
identifying variation at the genomic
and transcriptomic levels and
understanding
both the causes of cancer the hallmarks
of cancer
and some of the ways that this disease
progresses into different stages
so one of the important types of data
that we will speak about
is next generation sequencing and one of
the primary ways that you can analyze
next generation sequencing data in the
context of oncology
is called variant calling where we can
align multiple reads to the reference
genome identify germline mutations and
then
to also see somatic mutations that might
occur
as a result of cell division
now ultimately those mutations lead to
changes
at the mrna and protein level and so we
will also take a look at how to process
and analyze next generation sequencing
for
gene expression analysis so we'll take a
look at different steps of mapping
quantification
and differential gene expression that
would allow us to compare
a given sample to a control and really
understand different types of conditions
now oftentimes people think about the
analysis itself as a way to gain
insight into the biological components
that are manifested in pathways and gene
ontology terms and so we will talk about
how to use the same user-friendly tools
to understand
gene set and pathway enrichment analysis
ultimately these types of research data
sets
are allowing us to see the basic
mechanisms
that define cancer and so a lot of times
because of the limitations of
these cell lines organoids and animal
models
we would also like to understand the
real
patient situation and kind of what
happens in real life
and so because of that we're going to be
looking at such data repositories like
the national
center for biotechnology information or
ncbi
as well as the cancer genome atlas that
contains
a number of important data sets
multi-omics data sets from real patients
with a lot of clinical information
now we will be able to see how real
collections of data can show us whether
the insights from
different types of cell line studies and
animal model studies
could really be applicable to the
patient population at large
now we will also take a look at some
interesting publications that refine our
understanding
also about the effectiveness of
treatment of different types of cancers
and so there are collections of cell
line high throughput experiments
that essentially are designed to
illustrate the response of different
types of cell lines to different types
of treatments
and because these are cell lines derived
from real cancer patients
they provide a good insight into a
predictive analysis
of what might work for a given situation
now when we turn to the tcga data
we will see how there are a numerous
collection of risk factors outcomes all
kinds of metadata
that can inform these decisions about
treatment of cancer
and so we will review this literature
understand
what are these different types of
factors that should be considered
and learn to incorporate them into our
analysis
now to do all of this in a short period
of time we will need
some effective resources for learning
and research and so what we've designed
in the onyx logic bioinformatics
training programs
are important resources that will help
capture
this important information about the
biology and the background of cancer
the practical bioinformatics analysis
methods as well as translational skills
skills that you can
learn and apply to a number of different
projects
that you might be interested in so for
the different sections
of this program we will leverage a
number of different resources
that you can benefit from and use
to learn about genomics for example
asynchronous coursework with theoretical
materials
quizzes and practical assignments
cloud-based analytical server where you
can analyze large genomic data and
visualize the results of your analysis
the onyx logic playground where you can
practice and learn
coding in r and python as well as a
repository of curated
project examples with data sets that you
can try
and analyze and get reproducible results
now the courses and projects that we
have prepared for this program
include training as an introduction to
bioinformatics methods
an introduction to genomic data
transcriptomic data and the application
of bioinformatics in the context of
several different
projects including early detection of
cancer
and approach to personalized precision
treatment of cancer
as well as the immune response of
different cancer
factors throughout the course
you will also be given directions to
access the t-bone info platform for
bioinformatic processing
and analysis of genomic and
transcriptomic data
the platform includes demo pipelines as
well as
a data management console and analysis
cloud
infrastructure that you can run
bioinformatics pipelines for large data
sets
different stages of analysis are
performed in different sections of this
multi-omics platform
in many cases you will also be able to
take elements of that pipeline and learn
how to perform
the analysis using r and python
but before we continue to speak about
all of these different resources
and program itself i wanted to launch a
poll
really quickly and get your feedback
on a few different questions so the
first question that i have
is what is your current country of
residence
so we have a few different options usa
canada mexico brazil peru
argentina ecuador or other
the second question is what is your
current level of
education so it could be high school
bachelor's degree master's degree phd
faculty or postdoc or other and then
what is your current area of interest or
specialization
bioinformatics oncology
undecided or other so let's take a
couple of minutes
to answer some of these questions and
then i will pass this
presentation over to clinton who will
tell us more about his experience with
cancer research
and some of the program resources that
we will be going through in this
bioinformatics training program
all right
okay so clinton i'll pass it on to you
you can start sharing
okay thank you all right so i'll keep
the poll on the screen
um but you can start your part of the
presentation
all right that sounds great elia thank
you hello and every uh
hello and welcome everyone to
bioinformatics for precision oncology
this is a one month program that will
teach you the foundational skills
to analyze complex cancer data sets in
hopes to achieve
a scientific question these skills are
transferable to other types of data sets
however the primary focus will be
oncology
in in my part of the presentation i will
speak about
my personal experience with
bioinformatics
and how it led me to conduct research
studies
that looked at the basic biology behind
cancer
i will review the program schedule and
explain how the different topics
fit together providing an experience for
students and researchers
that are interested to apply
bioinformatics
to research studies related to cancer
i will also discuss some ways this
program can benefit you
such as the development of practical
skills
critical thinking and research finally
i will talk about what you can do to get
the most out of
the omics logic bioinformatics for
precision oncology program
precision medicine is changing the way
we understand
diagnose and treat cancer this
transformation is driven
by high throughput molecular data from
patients
animal models and large-scale cell line
experiments
what i will share with you today will
introduce you to the omics logic
bioinformatics for precision oncology
program
which is designed to provide training
and guidance
to students and researchers interested
in various omics data
but before we speak about the program
let me share a few points
about my background and the reason why
bioinformatics
is central to translational research in
oncology
my name is clinton kuna i completed my
bachelor's degree at carnegie mellon
university where i discovered my passion
for research
later on i decided to continue learning
about life sciences
as a result i now have two master's
degrees
one from the university of guelph and
the other from the university of ottawa
since i was interested in translational
bioinformatics i did a masters in
bioinformatics and another one in
molecular medicine
as a result i am familiar with
biomedical research
and as well as data analytics
cancer is extremely heterogeneous
even though the war on cancer that was
announced 70 years ago
has brought about many advances in our
understanding
of the basic mechanisms that lead to
tumor growth
and metastasis it is also
clear that current research did not
solve this problem
on the contrary we are learning more and
more about this complex condition
now with to show you how complex cancer
is
let me give you an example from my past
research
there are several proteins that play
different roles within certain contexts
for example c20 like kinase or slk
slk is a protein that plays an important
role in cellular processes
such as proliferation migration and
apoptosis
it affects embryo development and is
shown to play a role in tumor genesis
this was studied in a new induced
mammary tumor model
in mice these experiments showed that
slk knockout mice developed tumors
faster
and showed an increased expression of
sox10
an important biomarker in cancer
however in my own research we studied
slk and mouse embryonic fibroblasts
where slk knockout reduces focal
adhesion turnover
it turns out that slk plays different
roles depending on the context
even though this contradicts the other
study it also shows how complex
the biology of cancer can be and how
careful we have to be with experimental
design
and data analysis to truly understand
its
pathogenesis research on
slk is ongoing this is similar to cancer
every cancer is different and it's a
challenge to determine
why a knockout reduces a process in one
context
but increases it in another my master's
thesis gave me a glimpse of how
bioinformatics
can be used to study oncology and the
skills
i acquired enabled me to learn
more or use more sophisticated methods
of data analysis
such as machine learning
and other types of hard other types of
algorithms
so there's a lot of complexity with high
throughput data
and that you need complex
machine learning learning algorithms to
deal with it
therefore i decided to pursue a masters
in bioinformatics
and learnt those complex skills
pure biology is good but having the data
analysis skills to create meaningful
relationships
definitely solves major problems that
has been translated into applications
within medicine
bioinformatics has exposed me to other
fields due to its interdisciplinary
nature
such as statistics engineering and
mathematics
does anyone have any questions related
to the transition from biology to
bioinformatics
i have been through it and you can too
are most of you biologists or do you
have a bioinformatics background
i'm a biologist and uh i'm doing some
bioinformatics
nice you can if you feel shy to use the
microphone you can
type in the chat okay
okay
yeah all right
yeah this program is mainly for
it's mainly for biologists uh citizen
scientists
and people who have a genuine interest
in cancer
and biology so it it's a great
foundation to get into the field of
bioinformatics
especially if you have no previous
knowledge because
we have the toolkit to help you get up
to speed
so now let me explain how anyone
including you
can learn the same skills as i have and
apply them to a data set
by completing this program
the bioinformatics for precision
oncology program starts on march 15
and will go through april 9th during
this time
we will learn to apply analysis of
genomic and transcriptomic
data to the study of cancer biology
our focus will be on bioinformatics
methods
but we will use examples of data sets
taken from oncology projects
at the end of the program we are
encouraging you to apply the learned
skills
to data sets of your own choice during
that time
we will support your research to make
sure you can process
analyze and interpret data
we will learn important concepts within
cancer biology
such as the central dogma the hallmarks
of cancer
and how cancer is diagnosed and treated
several bioinformatics methods will be
talked about such as
processing variant calling rnac
and more finally we will look at
bioinformatics method we will look at
sample projects and learn how to
use our own projects with the our new
the learned bioinformatics methods
by learning these major concepts you
will be well equipped to start your own
projects
so if you haven't checked out the
precision precision oncology link
here is a snapshot of all the topic
topics we will cover
you can you can register with the link
above and i will re-show you the link
at the end of the presentation
in the first session on march 15 we will
review
introductory material about oncology
and the challenges associated with big
data in cancer research
in the session after that we will start
talking about next
generation sequencing
and and what this data can reveal about
biological processes
and the clinical manifestation of cancer
drivers
tumor development and the tumor micro
environment
finally in the last session of the first
week we will speak about challenges
of big data the data sets that have to
be processed
analyzed and annotated to yield insights
into cancer biology
and discuss what types of information we
can extract
from next generation sequencing data
in the first session we will start
talking about
cancer biology and the cellular at the
cellular and
tissue levels learning about the role of
dna changes and gene expression
variation
related to cancer risk progression and
and its outcomes in order to conduct
research on cancer
one needs to know its fundamentals the
content
of this session is related to what would
be taught in the beginning of any
cancer-based program
such as a master's degree this content
can equip someone who is completely new
to the field of oncology
no fun foundational concepts for more
advanced studies
one of the first concepts that we will
learn would be the hallmarks of cancer
what defines a cancer these are
distinctive
and complementary capabilities that
enable tomb
grow tumor growth and metastasis
metastasis
these hallmarks have evolved over the
past decade
the main concepts of the hallmarks
involve
rapid growth rapid spread evasion of the
host cell's defenses
increased mutation rate that transfers
to its daughter cells
and finally immortality
we will speak about the challenges of
big data sets
that have to be processed analyzed and
annotated
to yield insights into cancer biology
topics that will be covered include
hypothesis testing
data mining statistics and how to use
the tbio platform
has anyone taken a statistics course and
what are some techniques that you've
learned or are familiar
with please write a word or a sentence a
one sentence
in the chat just to get an idea of your
statistics background
yes okay perfect
taking stats
uh are you from are you an undergraduate
sylvia or a
graduate or what's your level of
education slash expertise
oh doctor i see two-tailed yeah
nice nice nice
so great you'll learn how to use
similar techniques um with it
within this program and apply them on
oncology data sets
the growth in height throughput
sequencing of cancer genomes and
transcriptomes has produced a lot of
data which slows down the progress
of cancer biologists and oncology
oncologists
from quickly and efficiently gleaning
knowledge
there are so many data sets that need to
be analyzed in order to find
relationships
between cancerous processes tumor
genomic profiles and treatment response
that's why we will learn about these
data types and how to efficiently
process and analyze
such data so just
what are the largest data sets that
you've all worked with
you can type a gigabyte amount in the
chat or
roughly describe the size
what's the largest data set you've ever
worked with
if you guys can remember that number
i i'll give you money
this is just uh
i i worked with uh something that
nice you can you can write your excel
sheets as well if you've
uh if you haven't worked with larger
data sets maybe
i think excel the maxima might be around
250 i don't know if you you guys have
ever probed into
the size of your data sets
but it's fine you will learn how to
analyze and work with big data sets in
this program
nice wow 20 gig that's that's that's
pretty big
nice so
you will learn how to analyze extremely
large biological data sets
using a remote system
the tbio platform has a large storage
space and it can handle large projects
so you can download really large data
sets and work with them
remotely so
can everyone you don't have to write a
lot
you can give me maybe a sentence or a
word
what what's your field or experience in
the field of bioinformatics
you can say none if it's your first time
or you can give a one sentence
description
if you
okay r nice yes that that's very
that's really good anyone else
has anyone never really used
bioinformatics you can say none
none okay
yep well this is actually a great
starting point so if this is the first
time you've heard of
a pine biotech or mix logic
or even bioinformatics i highly
recommend
checking out the following link on the
screen please start going through the
introduction to bioinformatics course
we have on the following web address
um if maybe elia could paste it in the
chat
or i can paste it at the end of the all
right perfect
yeah this this will give you a
introduction to what bioinformatics is
define the field so you can
have that foundational knowledge nice
wow 15 separate subjects
wow that's great that's that's great
that's great
i i can see you potentially upgrading
your
work
to maybe a graduate degree at some point
so we will we will also discuss
the types of information that can be
extracted from next generation
sequencing data
you will learn about how to process
analyze
and interpret genomics data through
specific pipelines
example techniques include variant
calling mapping
and finding the significance of specific
mutations
these are common techniques used in
hospitals to analyze sequencing data
from cancer patients in hopes to
diagnose
and potentially design an effective
treatment plan
with this skill set and a few projects
worth of experience
you could potentially be on the path to
help a
hospital near you
so can someone tell me the purpose of
looking at dna variation
there could be multiple purposes but
maybe in a sentence or one word how
would you describe um
[Music]
why would you want to look at dna
variation
like what purpose that does that serve
why do i
want to look at dna variations
okay i guess perfect okay
epidemiology of the virus yeah
all right so
for if you'd like a more general yes
okay to see how cancerous cells
operate for different types of dna in
people yeah
those are nice answers if if you'd like
a more general and in-depth answer
please check out the courses on the the
link
on the screen shown here
uh check out introduction to genomics
and genomics one courses they focus on
answering the following questions
what is dna variation and what types of
variation are there
what dna elements are being studied for
variation
and what types of genomic information
exist
and can be analyzed yes it could explain
some changes in the phenotype exactly
so if you yeah in in within the
precision oncology program
you will learn how to load ngs data
and construct data analysis pipelines
to find genetic genetic variants in
breast cancer
and you also do similar tasks
in the genomics program
so most of you come from a biology
background
so this question might be easy for you
what are three common types of dna
mutations
yeah okay yeah dna expression
that that could also be a another reason
why we look at dna variation
okay miss sense okay that's that's
what's good
nonsense yeah okay
there are more than three but
you know you can give me three so
you gave me two which is fine which is
fine
so yeah deletion yep
so yeah insertions perfect
yes so so
what some of the common ones are
insertions deletions substitutions
and structural ones so you might have an
extra chromosome
and usually in cancer these mutations
affect the following so they affect
tumor suppressor genes
oncogenes or dna repair genes
so that once those are affected then
the system you know it starts to get
buggy and then the hallmarks of cancer
come in
and then the cancer forms so
the image is shown
the images above show different single
nucleotide polymorphisms and some of the
steps in the ngs variant calling
pipeline so variant calling is useful to
determine which changes might
cause a particular phenotype just like
um
who said that i think someone mentioned
the phenotype yeah
matthias and um
there are three types of mutations that
just like we observed before
and during this program we will map
visualize and detect significant changes
in dna sequences using a reference
genome
and paired tumor normal samples
we will also spend considerable time
learning about gene expression
and rna-seq practicing each of the
analysis steps
on the user-friendly tbio platform you
will learn how to process
analyze and interpret next generation
sequencing data
so for a more in-depth course that
focuses just on transcriptomics
check check out our transcriptomic
series
these courses provide a broad but
detailed overview on key steps
such as processing statistical analysis
machine learning and single cell data
and
analysis techniques so they cover
they cover various methods various terms
provide practical examples and they also
have quizzes to check your understanding
the precision oncology program will also
use key concepts
from these series but it's more geared
towards cancer data sets
so has anyone heard of the term
differential gene expression
you can you can either say yes or
describe it in one sentence whichever
you feel comfortable
so have you heard of differential gene
expression okay yes
perfect we have a lot of biologists here
i i should see like so
uh several yeses
yes uh
we can relate to samples
yes and
it depending on it's close to it's
checking the significance
of genes between two uh
groups so i
i'd say it's more of two different
groups versus
two different completely different
diseases but i think there's a specific
pipeline for that
but within within the the context of
this course
we're going to focus on two different
groups
so maybe one one group has
one's the normal group and one's the
disease group
so related diseases um i
i believe i believe we can but we won't
be
doing the the example within this course
okay perfect so
researchers need a way to assess whether
gene expression values
have an actual significance between them
or whether those expression values were
caused by a technical issue
so differential expression analysis
means taking normalized gene expression
data and performing a test to see
the if there's significant changes
between
experimental groups so one example is
that we will prepare and
run a full processing pipeline
designed for differential gene
expression
so here's an example so here's one
condition
and here's another condition so one
might be normal and one might be
diseased
we will also learn to apply statistical
approaches like regression to study
differences between conditions that have
multiple factors other techniques
include
pca t-test and differential gene
expression
so factor analysis
models are used to describe a large
number of
observed variables by a smaller number
of unobserved
variables which are known as d factors
these factors explain all correlation
between
observed variables so by doing a factor
regression analysis
we will find relationships in data
and find significant genes that are
associated with cancer types
or stages that aren't noticeable at
first so
essentially what we're doing is finding
hidden variables
that can help us find stronger and find
stronger relationships
for future analysis so
i'll give you an example to explain this
concept
so for example let's take suppose there
are 20 movie reviewers
and they're asked to rate a movie from
one being bad to five
being excellent to different types of
movies
the first movie is the funny movie the
second one
is this will make you laugh the third
one is forbidden planet
fourth one is going to mars fifth one is
the history of china
and the sixth one is how is the world
changing
and the last one is how were the
pyramids built
it's possible that the reviewers
assigned ratings that may be correlated
with hidden variables such as comedy
science fiction and history because one
movie was called the funny movie and the
other one was called this will make you
laugh
and there may be the variable
hidden or the variable comedy
is a hidden variable
based on the previous sessions analysis
we will build upon that foundation
to deduce which genes are important for
future use
in biological interpretation using
several
methods that will help us gain a
systematic understanding of the
found genes without this step we would
just limit ourselves
with understanding that these two genes
are significantly different
but we wouldn't be able to translate
that
to a
observable phenotype most companies seek
bioinformaticians
to act as a bridge to annotate and
interpret their data
for an audience who might not understand
these scientific complexities
what are some genes that you know that
play a major role in cancer
you can just write the gene name and the
type of cancer you don't have to go into
too much detail
if you know of any cancer related genes
okay it's fine if you if you don't
so one example would be the bracha gene
brca and it's a common gene that's
affected yes
in in breast cancer
so after we've filtered for significant
genes
we can use other sources to deduce an
observable phenotype
[Music]
so therefore we'll learn about gene
enrichment analysis
gene set enrichment analysis
this this is used to determine pathways
that are activated
or deactivated in various tumors
it can help us pinpoint diseases or
pathways associated with significant
genes
with their own statistical algorithms we
will also speak about
pathway deregulation and the effect that
many subtle changes can have
on different conditions we have a nice
pipeline that will allow you to do this
analysis
in an easy and straightforward manner
gene set enrichment analysis will
produce output pipe
pathways such as the ones on the screen
associated with significant genes
collected from previous steps
these pathways will give us insight into
the by the biology of tumor development
and interaction with the micro
environment
knowing these pathways can help us
deduce other relationships
as well
in the next portion of this program we
will review some of the data sources and
databases
where you can leverage your current and
future research projects
you will learn how to access different
omics data from databases such as
ncbi tcga nci
and cosmic
to apply what we've learned we will
analyze data from cancer patients
we will review the most comprehensive
collections of omics
and clinical data found in the cancer
genome atlas or tcga
what types of cancer would you all be
interested in studying
you can write a one word answer or a
sentence
ovarian lung okay
addict all right
nice nice all right
nice i'm i'm i'm personally interested
in breast cancer
due to its impact on one of my family
members
cancer genomic genome atlas contains
data on
of 12 different cancer tumor types and
six different omics
layers that pertain to that data it has
data from thousands of patients we will
learn how to navigate
the genome data commons portal to find
multiple multi-omics data sets with
clinical information about the samples
you can then create your own projects
after you develop the skills to access
data
with an experienced team of
bioinformatics trainers
we will also cover databases like the
national cancer
institute genomic data comments
an information system for storing
analyzing and sharing genomic
and clinical data from patients with
cancer
the second database that we will learn
about is called cosmic
the catalog of somatic mutations in
cancer
it is the world's largest and most
comprehensive resource
for exploring the impact of somatic
mutations in human cancer
the national cancer institute genomic
data commons
gdc has 68 projects worth of data
that spans different parts of the body
as you can see in
on the schematic long bone marrow and
breast cancer data
sets appear to be the more common day
cancer data sets if a particular
type of data set interests you the pine
biotech
team can help you set up a project at a
later stage in the precision
oncology program
cosmic the catalog of somatic mutations
in cancer has more than one thousand
cancer cell lines
worth of data that can be used for
predictive
or other types of analysis an example
shown
in the bottom figure shows common
variants
within the classical hela cervical
cell cancer cell line accessing related
information on cosmic
can help you determine whether your
observed changes
within your experimental data set
translates to something already known
something new or something similar to
your hypothesized results
the last part of the program will be
dedicated to an independent project
that you can work on with the help of
our team after learning the required
skill set
you can formulate your own research
question and use our user-friendly
pipeline to answer that question this
project can be developed further
to become an academic project for your
institution
or other career level projects learning
project planning skills is extremely
useful in bioinformatics
because you will probably be working on
multiple projects
from different scientists
can someone briefly describe the
scientific process
you can say four words or you can write
a sentence
you don't have to go into too much
detail maybe the first word
like how would you describe the
scientific process if i want to
conduct an experiment right now what
would i do
we're all biologists i'm sure i'm sure
everyone knows the answer to this
okay yeah obviously in hypothesis those
are nice keywords
now search for a data set okay
yep use a large sample size
okay
yep so the
the process that i'm about to tell you
isn't set to stone but it's the general
process
so you ask yourself what's your research
question
what rationale can you use to justify
your project
what methods will you use to achieve
that project
and what do you anticipate on obtaining
based on your
proposed pipeline or project
we will touch upon important aspects of
project design
and proposals looking to maximize
aim of the project that's good looking
to maximize
the value of a proposed project
scientific projects should form a
specific structure
in order to ensure efficiency in time
management
and resource allocation
prior literature review will give you an
insight on what is out there
and help you provide the foundational
rationale to your proposed project
afterwards you can create afterwards you
can create a project proposal
which includes a rationale to your
project related methods background on
the topic of interest
and anticipated results these steps are
foundational in
all types of scientific projects such as
grant writing and thesis writing
we will also go through several examples
of projects to learn about
successful application of data analysis
tools
to large omics datasets the first
example will use cell line data to
classify
subtypes of cancer this project will
illustrate the base scope of what you
should be able to achieve
after you've learned the required skill
set
if you'd like to take your project to
the next level you can talk to our
bioinformatics team
can someone give me a short definition
of a cell line
or have i'm have you used cell lines
before you can say yes
or you can describe what a cell line is
yeah that's a famous one
you can give examples to
cho cells what do you mean by cho
cells or cho
like single colony cells is uh
okay because yeah in
oh yeah okay nice
okay okay
interesting yeah these are
yeah some of these cell lines are new or
i haven't heard of
one of them the 2 2 7 8 0 but
interesting
that's awesome i i so
a cell line is a general term that
applies to a defined population of cells
so usually they're maintained in a
culture so
people use media and put different
nutrients so the cells can grow
constantly for certain experiments
so in this example project we will take
a data set
from the publication modeling precision
treatment of breast cancer
which was featured in genome biology in
20 2013.
the publication is interesting because
the authors assembled a data set
of about 50 different breast cancer cell
lines that represent the whole
spectrum of breast cancer variations
the cell lines have genomic
transcriptomic and proteomic data
as well as drug officious c
measurements of commonly used and
experimental
cancer drugs
project example will be dedicated to
liver cancer
where risk factors like obesity and
viral infection
can play a major role in progression and
outcomes
we will take samples from the liver
hepatocellular carcinoma
lihc tcga project
and see how various clinical data
available on those patients can be used
in analysis
of gene and micro rna expression
the multi-omics project uses
sophisticated
sophisticated algorithms such as
similarity network fuse
fusion or snf to find correlations
between different types of data
multi-omics approaches add more insights
due to the multiple levels of analysis
and you are using this
more data on the same type of experiment
to solve an important problem
so by the end of this course you should
achieve the following learning outcomes
you should be able to read and
understand bioinformatics literature
perform ngs basic ngs analysis
analyze data and form a hypothesis
prepare data from machine learning
cross check signals with gene databases
know what type of data is required to
answer scientific questions
create your own bioinformatics analyses
and present your results in an organized
way
all of these skills are essential in
bioinformatics and some can be
translated to other fields
so after achieving the learning outcomes
you would have learned some of the major
best practices in the field of
bioinformatics
you will be exposed to r and python two
powerful programming languages
bioinformaticians will need to
understand how to use t-test
regression and other tests analyzing and
managing data
is in order to communicate important
information is another breast
best practice in bioinformatics pipeline
development and utilization is another
common practice
ultimately completing the precision
oncology program
will help you enter the field of
bioinformatics
since you'll learn several best
practices
at the end of the program participates
the participants will receive
a certificate of participation
as you can see on the screen here the
certificate
can help you obtain a bioinformatics
position in another institute
add experience to your belt or build
your cv for
a graduate or undergraduate program in
bioinformatics
jobs within bioinformatics usually
require
experience with analyzing complex data
sets and this certification
can help can make you stand out and give
you that experience
and the link is on the bottom
we welcome you to join this program and
learn about the
application of bioinformatics in
precision oncology
this program is geared towards citizen
scientists
biologists who would like to learn
important bioinformatics skills
bioinformaticians who would like to
improve their existing skill set
and anyone who is interested in the
fields in the field of bioinformatics
with special emphasis on precision
oncology
if you feel like there is a topic that
we haven't mentioned
within bioinformatics research in
oncology and you are interested in
learning more about
please type it in the chat and we could
think about integrating it for future
lessons
does anyone have any particular
questions for now
you can type it in the chat
thank you clinton uh we're running out
of time here so
i just wanted to um thank you all for
joining today
and i want to point your attention to a
couple of
important links that clinton and i have
already shared in the chat
here you can see the place where you can
finalize your registration if you're
ready
to do that so this is where you can
see all of the details about the
individual
meetings that we have scheduled starting
from march 14th
and then you will also see what topics
are covered in each one of the sessions
there's an overview video and if you're
ready to complete your registration
you can just go to get started
and see some of the options here for
program registration
now in addition to that we offer
asynchronous learning which is much more
affordable
and provides you with the same quality
materials and resources that will be
covered
in the program itself but without
the mentorship and the interactive
sessions
that are included in the program so to
gain access to here you can actually
register for free
this is the link learn.omixlogic.com
you can go inside once you have
completed your registration
and take a look at some of the
coursework that includes
getting started with bioinformatics and
r and python
introduction to data science
introductory courses to different topics
and
projects including some of the projects
that will be covered
in this precision oncology program
do we offer so again the pricing here a
lot of materials here are free so you're
welcome to get started here and if you
like it you can explore more
there are some uh premium resources here
that utilize some of the bioinformatics
infrastructure so those are also priced
very affordably but if you're interested
in actually joining the program
we do have a process where you can apply
for a scholarship
so we welcome you to first of all write
to us at marketing at pine.bio
and you can describe there why you're
seeking a scholarship
and we will send you a link to a form
where you will be able to register for a
scholarship
and schedule an appointment with one of
our team members
to learn about your background and your
interests
so um i wanted to also
let you know that this program has been
completed by
a number of different students
researchers
and clinicians and here are some
examples so
uh olga udartseva was a research postdoc
at roswell park comprehensive cancer
center and she has completed the
training that we described today
she found that the course materials
helped her gain a
sense of how bioinformatics can help her
but also apply
the skills that she has learned to a
project a clinical project that she was
working on
we also have people that come from
different backgrounds for example
dan neil is a statistician at university
of florida and had to deal with a lot of
research data coming from life sciences
and so he
took the courses to understand where
does the
where is the application of
biostatistics to biomedical data
we also had a number of undergraduate
students from
universities like the xavier university
of louisiana
that were exposed for the first time to
bioinformatics pipelines methods of
analysis and big data
graduate students for example aaron
sugimanto who was a graduate student at
california state university in long
beach california
and he was pleased with the content and
kind of found it
interesting and applicable to his
research
so we are excited to start this program
the program will start march 15th
and so we welcome you to join and please
to
be on the lookout for additional
materials that we will be sending
including a recorded version of this
webinar if you want to review it again
you're welcome to reach out to us and
send
any questions or requests for more
information
to marketing at pine bio and we'll be
able to send that over to you
as well so again thank you everyone for
joining today
we are excited to get started with this
program it's going to start very soon
and we have a number of other programs
that are coming up or
ongoing and so if you're interested in
those just feel free to reach out to us
now if you have any questions we're
going to stick around here for just a
couple more minutes we are already out
of time
uh but if you do have any questions feel
free to post them in the chat
and i will stop sharing for now and
again
thank you for joining we are looking
forward to seeing you in the program